and exercise is supposed to be good for
you and of course the darling of the
medical system for exercise was Jim Fixx
he was a long-distance runner he was a
professor of economics and one of the
Ivy League schools and here's the
darling of the medical world because
when he was interviewed on TV and asked
if he took any vitamins minerals he says
now you don't need to do that
don't take any vitamins minerals just
run you'll keep your arteries clean well
he dropped dead while he was running a
marathon at age 52 and so his theory
didn't work it was a failed theory his
protege Brian Maxwell from Canada died
at 51 while he was running he had 12
gold medals for long-distance running
three were in the Olympics and he
invented the power bar and he sold the
rights to the power bar to Nestle's
corporation and three months after he
received his three million dollars he
drops dead during a run cardiomyopathy
heart disease a deficiency of a single
mineral just like Jim Fixx now because
of this the general American Medical
Association did a literature review and
which is published in December of 1982
in September of 1982 Jim Fixx died and
they did this literature search because
he was their hero and they these were
just really freaking out because here we
are our hero dies of a heart attack
while he's running and they published it
as a kind of letter to the editor thing
in the journal American Medical
Association in 1982 also they published
it later on as an abstract in running
world or runners world magazine and they
said while running a man's risk of heart
attack death increases by 700 percent
while running increased by a factor of
707 now that shocked everybody because
they thought exercise was good mom when
you take all professional athletes of
all sports combined and you look at them
from an average lifespan their average
lifespan is 62 when you take out
professional football players their
average lifespan is 51 there's never
been a professional athlete ever live to
be a hundred so what does that say to
you about exercise there's something
problematic about exercise it's not what
it was led to believe it was so what's
going on here is when you sweat you're
not sweating out water sweat is not
water but yet athletes will go to great
and extends to rehydrate using water or
they'll drink these sports drinks that
have to
nutrients Enver six nutrients and as a
result to begin to break down they'll
get torn cartilage in their knees to get
core torn cartilage in their hips so
good torn muscles torn tendons or
achilles tendon though we had cramps
forget all kinds of stuff and they have
to get taken off the field on the
stretcher and so on and then some of
them died okay because they're sweating
out all the nutrients floating around
their blood if they're not supplementing
they might only have 55 or 60 nutrients
which you're sweating out if they're
supplementing they may have 90 but if
you're not supplementing and you're
exercising you're in real trouble okay
Reggie Lewis captain the Boston Celtics
collapsed during a playoff game with
Charlotte Hornets he survived that first
cut him up with a heart attack and he
was given a drug to kind of support his
heart function and he was told to do
light exercise like throwing free show
threw like throwing free throws from the
free-throw line on a court and two weeks
later after his initial attack he died
of a second cardiomyopathy a heart
attack
if Reggie Lewis had been given ten cents
worth of selenium he'd still be alive
today
has he died of a simple selenium
deficiency disease Moses Malone NBA Hall
of Famer dies at sixty of a
cardiomyopathy heart attack rowdy roddy
piper dies at 61 from a cardiomyopathy
heart attack this fella here a
cardiologist and a soccer star in brazil
drops dead at age 57 from a
cardiomyopathy heart attack so why is it
the strangeness exercises and healthy is
because you must supplement to replace
all the nutrients you're sweating out
really that's simple obesity as we
pointed out in the beginning is not due
to eating too much lack of exercise
obesity is in fact a simple nutritional
deficiency and there's no end in sight
for the obesity epidemic because those
nutrients are disappearing from our food
faster and faster these symptoms you get
from that deficiencies are cravings
binge eating and the munchies
experts tell us that 70% of our kids
under the age of 12 are overweight 40%
of our kids under the age of 12 or obese
30 pounds or more of their ideal weight
for their height and this has nothing to
do with eating too much or lack of
exercise this is caused by a nutritional
deficiency totally preventable totally
reversible quite quickly - half a pound
- two pounds a day
this is a kind of a false story is a
false flag attack so to speak I
guarantee this little baby who's under
two years of age is not eating super
sized bags of french fries not gonna
happen but he is obese and if he was
eating these french fries and continued
to eat them from that on the odds are he
would die of a coronary artery disease
at age 10 or 12 years of age because of
the trans fats hetero psychic means in
the acrylamide in the french fries he's
obese because he's deficient in
nutrients now this is everywhere USA in
1920 this is when they began the theory
that lack of exercise and eating too
much was the cause of obesity
of course these girls are getting a lot
of giggles here but this has nothing to
do with their cause of obesity or their
repair with themselves or getting rid of
their obesity they're gonna have fun
they're gonna waste some time but
they're not going to solve their
problems here it's a nutritional
deficiency problem here's a mother in
Brazil who ate 20 bath sponges with soap
suds and skin dandruff in it as well as
the the parrot droppings as well as the
sand at the bottom of the parrot cage
because she had such crazy cravings of
course pregnant women are legendary for
gaining baby fat during pregnancy echoes
are missing nutrients because the embryo
stealing nutrients some of them faster
than they're getting them themselves and
this is Ivan of course met him about
three years ago and Ivan weighed 423
pounds when I met him he lost on our
program whether supplementation and
nutrients lost 17 pounds in the first
week he lost 60 pounds in the first 30
days as 2 pounds a day and he dropped
down from 400 pounds 165 pounds in seven
months and two years later his pictures
on the right and he of course two years
later is still looking good and and
hasn't gained back a quarter of an ounce
and this is because this is a simple
nutritional deficiency you take the
nutrients it goes away you take the
nutrients you don't get fat just as
simple in horses the the behavior called
munchies is called cribbing and see here
the horse is not even in that stall in
the barn as a horse-and-buggy Amish farm
and which is south of Fort Wayne Indiana
and the buggy is bringing the babies
with must risk fear Layton being a
physician and a veterinary and I said
well there's a barn cow go look at the
animals and sure enough there's a
cribbing evidence there so I knew that
that horse in that barn was deficient
deficient in minerals you give him
minerals and it stops you give people to
write minerals and the obesity goes away
it's just very simple as he approached
his north right is simple mineral
deficiencies simple vitamin deficiencies
it's not a complex disease at all it's
as simple nutritional deficiency every
tissue in our body
every organ or body wants to go away
it's kind of like sand on a beach or
paint on your house over time getting
beat up from the weather and the
temperature changes and so forth what
happens is is everything goes away well
if you're not taking in the raw
materials to maintain it like paint your
house every year right that kind of
thing change your oil every 3,000 miles
you're gonna have problems and arthritis
and talking about the coming epidemic of
arthritis that's because we no longer
have the right nutrients in our food
anymore we'll get into that in a moment
now colas are linked to bone breaks
fractures because when you take in
calcium for your bones and oftentimes
doctors will do that just give people
calcium you need all 90 essential
nutrients for bone health but if you're
gonna take in calcium along with the
other nutrients you have to have the
right ratio between calcium and
phosphorus has got to be - calcium for
one phosphorus if everything is gonna
work well if you drink colas even diet
colas regardless of what brand of coal
it is guess what you're gonna have for
phosphorus for one calcium and that
scenario is going to leech all the
minerals out of your bones and that's
why you find a lot of young athletes get
fractures just running down the field
because they're drinking lots of colas
calcium deficiency causes kidney stones
the first thing in a medical doctor will
tell you is stop eating dairy and for
goodness sakes don't supplement with any
calcium when in fact calcium deficiency
is the cause of kidney stones what
happens is your parathyroid glands don't
like that they reach into your bones and
they suck out minerals particularly
calcium and that calcium that your
parathyroid gland is pulling out of your
bones raises your calcium Levin you're
raising your calcium level in your blood
as well as causes kidney stones
failed medical theory copy gravis you
approach these drugs are linked to hip
fractures why is that you know 1-800 bad
drugs why is that because they were
phosphorus Fosamax
too much phosphorus none of calcium and
it causes demineralization of your bones
another failed medical theory big
surprise another failed medical theory
is that osteoporosis is caused in women
when they go through menopause because
they don't have enough estrogen to keep
calcium their bones that's an absolute
lie it's not true men you actually get
osteoporosis at a faster rate than women
more seriously and fast rate you see all
these little old guys with canes
wobbling around in the in the malls and
airports and shopping centers and
grocery stores and so forth they have
osteoporosis and of course this is a
failed theory that women got it men
didn't because women went through
menopause had reduction lost their
hormones that was a nonsense absolute
criminal theory and somebody should go
to jail for that one because they killed
so many men who fell and had hip
fractures when they should have been on
mineral supplements prevent that this
young fella here the Prince of Dubai
Sheikh Rashid died at 33 while he was
running you can see he's a very fit
young fella runner played soccer played
rugby and he was held up as the kind of
fitness guru and Dubai kind of leading
the country and their health he was also
the guy who's gonna become the king when
the King died and he drops out at age 33
while he was running a cardiomyopathy a
heart attack a simple deficiency of a
single mineral and so hopefully we're
going to Dubai and to teach the people
there that they have to supplement no
matter how wealthy are you still need a
supplement to make sure your tissues are
receiving everything they need terrible
tragedy
terribly unnecessary Andy young from the
civil rights movement also he is the
ambassador United Nations under Jimmy
Carter he was the mayor of Atlanta for a
couple of terms and he called me from
San Diego to come to Atlanta in his home
and speak to him because of my work in
sickle cell anemia
not being genetic and we were talking
about that and I noticed he was limping
I said with all due respects mr.
ambassador why are you limping he said
well I got bone to bone or I suppose my
knees and I'm scheduled at Emory
University the group that fired me for
my fibrosis research to have a
double knee replacement I said sir with
all due respect I can regrow you're
carly shay I can support and promote
major
pair by supplementing with a program we
called the healthy bone and joint pact
he said well these are the best surgeons
orthopedic surgeons in the world and
they say can't me said well sir with all
due respect they're liars okay we can't
in fact support and promote maintenance
repair and you will regrow your
cartilage and he didn't want to have the
surgery so he canceled the surgery and
let me rebuild his knees in 90 days we
rebuilt his knees and we became very
good friends and we do lots of great
things around the world together one of
the things he did was introduce me to
this young lady
delecia jones she was the center on the
u.s. women's Olympic team that had won
two gold medals in the Olympics so the
basketball team and getting prepared for
their third run at the Olympics she tore
her hamstring and Achilles tendon on the
right hand side and the surgeons were
gonna put her together said delecia you
know we can put you together
mechanically but you might not play at
the same skill level because of these
injuries are very devastating and you
might consider coaching well she didn't
like that she went to Andy young and he
referred her to me again using the
healthy bone and joint pact were able to
support and promote maintenance repair
of the muscles and the tendons and
ligaments and cartilage regrew her and
they went back and won their third gold
medal and this is me giving her an award
a certificate for sharing her story with
other athletes and I often wonder why do
women who were 6 foot 5 wear 8-inch
heels okay
knee surgery arthritis is worthless this
was a study from Harvard Medical School
published in the New England Journal of
Medicine this was a July 2002 and this
is where we like to refer people they
looked at 300,000 sets of records from
people who had knee replacement hip
replacement shoulder replacement
surgeries they found out that the
disease just kept getting worse and
worse you had to replace that device
every couple of years because the bone
would get thinner and thinner and
actually might tear and rupture and
break and so they said ultimately knee
replacement surgeries for a surprise hip
replacements and shoulder replacements
are worthless and so you know give us 90
days with a healthy bone or joint pack
and let us support and promote
maintenance repair and see what happens
you're gonna be very happy because by
supporting and promoting Maynard pair we
can support and promote repair and
reappearance and regrowth of that
cartilage no matter what your doctor
says is doable
four years later November 2006 that same
group of artha peak surgeons from
Harvard Medical School looked at the
same 300,000 records but this time they
looked at the backs of these same people
they said back surgery unnecessary for
sciatica low back pain for things like
peripheral neuropathies and so again we
can support promote maintenance repair
with the what we call the healthy bone
and joint pack it has all 90 essential
nutrients in it and gives the body the
raw materials it needs to support and
promote maintenance repair diabetes
there's an epidemic right now in the
world it's doubling diabetes is doubling
almost every year now in America right
now in America 30% of Americans either
have diabetes or prediabetes
is breaking us financially is breaking
the american medical system financially
okay is breaking our country financially
it is one of the big contributing
factors to the national debt of almost
19 trillion dollars is type 2 diabetes
why is it an epidemic because there's
none of this mineral in the soil
remember it's a deficiency of a single
mineral we've known that for almost 80
years it's a big story to show you it's
not a genetic disease goes to the Pima
Indians and above the line where the
line goes through the pee and underneath
the eye under Pima you see a big yellow
band looks like a big yellow banana
there in the eastern part of Mexico but
above that line that goes through the
pee and underneath the eye you'll see
it's the same genetic pool at whole
yellow area above that line which is the
border for Arizona between Arizona and
Mexico mainland of Mexico and below that
border you can see a big yellow swath
that is the range of the Pima Indians
they're one of the few Native American
tribes that did not enter mix with other
Indian tribes they did not intermix with
the Release black slaves after the Civil
War was over they never intermixed with
the explorers from Spain and Portugal
and France and Germany and so they're
almost pure same genetic pool across the
American border in the American side and
below the American border in the Mexican
side and here's a couple of pictures of
the Pima Indians same genetic pool now
remember that's the exact same genetic
pool the group of young men on your left
or Pima Indians they're typical of those
in Mexico they're tall and slim
they live in a third world country
situation don't have any of the
amenities of the Western world they're
still using horses or plowing and been
wagons the whole stuff around gone by
horses and they look pretty good the
ones on the right are above the border
in America in Arizona you see they're
all obese even the children are obese
and they have their vans and their
pickup trucks and so forth they all work
in factories instead of being
subsistence farmers like the ones in
Mexico let's have a look at the rate of
diabetes the Mexican Pima Indians have a
rate of type 2 diabetes of 6% the
American PM Indians which are written up
is the culture in America that has the
highest rate of type 2 diabetes
46% the average American rate is
considered like 33% 1/3 and so they are
30% higher than that 46% now we know
it's not genetic because it's the same
genetic pool so what could it be well we
know it's a mineral deficiency but why
there's a thin line going between those
two peoples and yet there's such a
difference between them why is this
you'll see in just a moment again
diabetes cases double kids are being
born with type 2 diabetes now not only
type 1 diabetes for they're being born
with type 2 diabetes and here's a three
and a half year old okay from Houston
and she's three and a half years of age
but she weighs as much as a ten year old
and she has type 2 diabetes where blacks
lose legs to diabetes then why it's this
is one of those things where the black
gene book comes in black gene lies more
blacks was a leg to diabetes and whites
why is that it's not a genetic thing is
because the medical system has been able
to capture the black community and tell
them that all their diseases are genetic
and if they stick with the medical
community the medical doctors will say
to them from their genetic diseases and
so whatever the doctor says they don't
question it they don't get a second or
third opinion they just do what the
doctor says and the doctor abuses them
financially as well as kills them early
this fella here Jerry Murphy owns one of
the largest medical diagnostic labs in
America gamma labs gamma labs and he had
terrible type genovese was running well
over 200 his blood running well over 200
his a 1 C hemoglobin was like 9 or 12
instead of 5 or below and make a long
story short
we made a wager because we had a mutual
friend who said I could help him with
his diabetes and he's very skeptical of
course working with the medical
community and he says look Wallach we'll
be best friends we'll do a lot of good
things for America together if you can
do what you say if you can't I will
destroy you
I'm gonna make a CD I'll have bounty
hunters pass them out everywhere you go
and I will dog you until you're
destroyed if you fail is okay Jerry
you're on
he's quite shocked that I so quickly I
said okay let's do it I'll make a long
story short in three months time his a1c
hemoglobin was below five and his blood
sugar was down to like 90
we've been running too far T okay and
he's now totally diabetes free he's a
wonderful friend and we just love him to
pieces because he does great things for
us too cancer is not a genetically
transmitted disease it is a
self-inflicted disease everything you do
either prevents cancer it causes cancer
and so let's have a look
doctors and researchers they're so
interested because it's such a horrible
disease they want to run in get the cure
right away and they fail every time to
find the cure the first prevention
research was done in published in 1912
it was on the benefits of selenium and
preventing cancer they published in
Popular Mechanics magazine why did they
publish something like that and Popular
Mechanics magazine that's because they
brought it to all the medical journals
of the day and they wouldn't they
wouldn't publish it
that's nutrition we're not interested in
that that was 1912
well 1998 the University of Arizona
redid the same study redid it got the
same exact results showing they could
reduce the risk of prostate cancer by
65% 69% you reduced the risk of breast
cancer by 32% reduce the risk of
colorectal cancer by 95% by
supplementing with selenium published it
in the annals of Medicine which is very
well-respected Medical Journal
high fiber diets don't cut colon cancer
rates as another failed theory bacon ham
sausages are big cancer threat equal to
smoking and working in an asbestos
environment now I've been yelling about
this for forty five years since I did
those autopsies in the Center for the
biology of natural systems and the World
Health Organization two weeks ago made
the announcement the world health care
as a simple polish report on Monday
which was two weeks ago on the dangers
of eating processed meats the world
Cancer Research Fund has warned for
several years that there is strong
evidence that consuming a lot of
processed meats cause consuming a lot of
processed meats such as ham bacon and
salami increases the risk of colon
cancer and many other types of cancer
okay they also say that it probably I'm
quoting them now probably all red meat
causes cancer that's not true it's how
you cook the red meat okay will be a
factor this was study published in 1998
from the University of South Carolina
and they were working on the Harvard
Nurses Health Study 90,000 versus 20
years and their piece was to evaluate
the rate of breast cancer and women and
how they cooked their food okay they're
getting down into that area of interest
we found out that the women who cooked
their meat very well-done where the fat
was severely browned er burnt increased
their risk of breast cancer by 462
percent the ones who clipped their meat
medium-rare and the fat remained white
reduce the risk of breast cancer by 460
percent so that's a nine hundred percent
difference between the most extreme
you're going to get it to the most
extreme you're not going to get it and
what a wonderful thing you just how you
cook your food determines whether you
can actually get breast cancer or not
and then there were some wonderful
research by dr. Gerhard schröder great
biochemists from University of
California who showed very clearly that
you could reduce the risk of breast
cancer by 82 percent just by
supplementing with 200 micrograms 1/5 of
a milligram of the trace mineral
selenium remember you said mammograms
are not prevention and they're dangerous
because one mammogram it has the
radiation equal to a 500 chest x-rays
also we find out that this is very
recent in October of 2015
61% 61% of all positive mammograms
our neck are false positives and they
say you know we just this is too
complicated here so we have to have a
biopsy
get a biopsy you know this is
unequivocal
but we're concerned and so let's air on
let's take the breast off a new
radiation and and chemotherapy so they
get their hit in they build an insurance
company or Medicare Medicaid for a
couple hundred thousand dollars and
doctors Hampi kills a patient hot dogs
cause butt cancer this is directed
towards kids these are highway signs you
begin seeing on the highways around
America genetics have nothing to do with
cancer have nothing to do with cancer
seating fried foods processed meats from
nitrates and nitrites cause of problems
arsenic is known to be an essential
nutrient since 1947 1947 and today even
the medical school of the New York
University proved unequivocally that
they could put people with acute
promyelocytic leukemia the most vicious
the most aggressive type of leukemia
into remission in just a couple of
months and 10 12 15 years later they're
still in remission they didn't want to
call it a cure because it's a essential
nutrient Steve Jobs dies of 56
satoru iwata CEO of Nintendo dies a 55
his parents buried him at age 55
dementia there's five different types of
dementia there's no law that says you
can't have all five faster dementia
arteries are clogged in your brain same
weather cloudy in your heart in your in
your kidneys Allison disease a
cholesterol deficiency of Korsakoff
syndrome I'd efficiency of a single
vitamin Warnecke Korsakoff syndrome
which is that deficiency that single
vitamin and also ms mix in with it
hold Westeros Asst madam b12
see dementia you can have all five of
these at the same time okay now remember
Elsa disease is caused by a cholesterol
deficiency it is not genetic not caused
by aluminum this is my favorite slide on
Alison Rosie's the mother is 82 years
old the son's 58 they're both have
Alzheimers these are both in the same
nursing home they both have the same
doctor they're on the same cluster
restricted diet they're on the same
statin drug prescribed of that doctor
the doctor also owns the nursing home
therein you should be getting a picture
here somebody needs to go to jail this
came out in 1992 and this is one of the
reasons in my original audio cassette
tape did dr. gentle I was so
controversial vitamin E Candy's memory
loss and alzheimerís victims and I added
a prepositional phrase when I read this
this was research from the Salk
Institute in the year resume of
California of San Diego vitamin E may
ease memory loss Nelson was victims
which means it cannot be genetically
transmitted because there's no vitamin
there's no pharmaceuticals couldn't
affect how a a Jake disease manifests
itself two years later the Johns Hopkins
School of Medicine very famous very
well-respected in Baltimore Maryland
went to the Cache Valley Utah and they
found 5,000 people over the age of 65
who had no dimension no serious disease
no heart disease high blood pressure
kidney disease nothing and so they found
them they put them on two vitamins
vitamin C and vitamin E because they
were excited about this vitamin E story
that came out two years earlier and ten
years later again they had half these
5000 people on this supplement and the
other half they put on a dummy pill at
the end of the ten years 2004 they
opened up the envelope and undid the the
map and the one's got the vitamin C and
E had 78% less Allison disease now they
all ate the same way because they're all
from the same culture they all came from
Scotland all these five 5000 people came
from the same religion they're Mormons
so they read the book of Mormon they are
also using the supplement to called the
words of wisdom which tells them what to
eat what not to kind of like the Jewish
kosher approach
and so there's more to it than just
those two vitamins also they were all
subsistence farmers much like Amish very
very basic very conservative farmers
only ate what they grew no restaurants
or hotels in their in their Valley where
they lived and so he actually had an
analysis done to the floor of that
entire Valley we know all the mineral
veins and everything what's in there and
so in the book epigenetics it goes into
great detail why these people had such a
wonderful reduction in the rate of
Alessandro disease just by supplementing
those two vitamins vitamin C knee
because they enhance the value and
function of other things is why type-2
diabetes has got to be Jeanette because
we have three generations of type 2
diabetics in our family no that's not
true if you ever heard of gluten
intolerance lutein intolerance is a
generational it's not genetic it's not
an allergy but it is generational and it
causes eczema dermatitis of all kinds
belly problems belly pain headaches all
kinds of nasty stuff celiac disease
appendicitis diverticulitis bowel
syndrome inflammatory bowel disease
Crohn's disease asthma chronic
bronchitis pneumonia every wintertime
eczema rosacea dermatitis psoriasis
infertility it can contribute to a
thousand other diseases because these
other diseases are nutritional
deficiencies and gluten intolerance
changes the efficiency of absorption out
of your intestines
you can't absorb the nutrients you have
a problem but let's say let's talk about
type 2 diabetes and you only have 2% of
the mineral you need to prevent diabetes
in the soil where you're living you're
eating from local farmers markets and
now you have a gluten intolerance and
you only have 10% of your availability
of absorption so what's 10 percent to 2
percent 0.2% you're going to get
diabetes
it has nothing to genetics and here is
the villa those little red finger like
projections on the left-hand side of
your screen
and these villi increase the absorber
surface the intestine when here's a
study on white rats on your left-hand
side or the healthy villi you can see
the little villi there's a microscopic
picture obviously
normal ones you can see all the
increased surface for absorption in the
middle picture those same group of rats
were put on a heavy gluten diet for six
months you can see the loss of the villi
and the scar tissue beginning
in between them on the right-hand side
it's a year of a heavy gluten diet and
look at all the scar tissue they've lost
almost 100 cent of their villi and the
intestinal lining is replaced with scar
tissue how do you absorb nutrition
through there you can't and this is what
gluten does to you it's kind of like
putting poison ivy on your skin you get
a contact dermatitis with gluten you get
a contact enteritis
okay inflammation intestines caused by
this protein which is very very
irritating okay now the nice thing about
this is if a ten year old kid or a three
year old kid or a six month old kid
gives on a gluten free diet and a couple
of weeks time you're gonna see a
dramatic benefit particularly for giving
them the 90s sense of nutrients let's
say somebody in their 20s and 30s and
40s because in a gluten free diet within
a month you're gonna see something
dramatic in a positive way and it might
take them a full year to repair people
who are in their 50s 60s 70s and 80s
been eating gluten five times a day and
oatmeal for breakfast every day drinking
a couple of beers every Friday night and
having bread and pasta and crackers and
gluten and whole grains all the time it
might take him two years to get a return
to normal on a gluten-free diet but they
might show some dramatic thing you can
see is a benefit more than maybe six
months it just depends on how long and
how severe the gluten damage is here's a
perfect example Lou you see on your left
is born with eczema and asthma his
mother was born with the same eczema
asthma she's 28 years old when she
delivered him she had three miscarriages
and she had the same eczema asthma and
she's breastfeeding him so we gave her a
gluten free diet we put her on the 19th
century nutrient 60 mineral 16 vitamins
12 amino acid 3 fatty acids and in two
weeks time harrasment rags my she had
for 28 years went away in the same two
weeks you see in the middle there his
asthma eczema went away in two weeks
time because he's getting all his
nutrients for his mother's breast milk
now here's your thing thing about this
the pediatrician who's caring for him
the only thing he told the mother was
here some hydrocortisone cream rub it on
his skin to prevent the itching and also
I told her to clip his fingernails and
put mittens on his hands to it and
scratching himself in the sleep well
here he is on the right at two years of
age and you can see how happy he is you
can tell by looking at him he doesn't
have asthma and eczema
we see this all the time in kids and the
ones on the Left have their eczema
dermatitis psoriasis and the ones on the
right they
without gluten for anywhere from a month
six months and they're getting the 90s
sense of nutrients you can see the
difference very dramatic this lady was
this way for twenty three years her
dermatologist made three million dollars
treating her for 23 years and of course
in 90 days gluten-free diet 90 essential
nutrients this is all reversible
longevity one in five Americans are
disabled 20% of Americans are disabled
we're supposed to have the finest
medical system the what we don't we have
the most expensive medical system in the
world but it's problematic
remember the eighty five percent of all
personal bankruptcies America due to
medical bills did you show you the
prevalence it's the same pattern in the
continental United States it's always
the south eastern states it's always the
Atlantic border there we run up and down
the Atlantic Ocean and also the states
around the Great Lakes also the
southwestern states and up in the
northwest where they have Indian tribes
there's the worst of the worst when it
comes to disabilities here okay this is
cancer here's one a little bit of
torture the the state that has the worst
cancer rate is Kentucky and of course
the reason why they have such terrible
cancer is there's very few of the
minerals in the Atlantic seaboard it was
very few of these minerals in the south
of eastern part of the nights' a sealed
Confederate States and the Indian
Reservation is out west there's one
particular state they fry everything
Kentucky they fry everything is rumored
they fry water and that's why they have
such a high rate of cancer life
expectancy the red yellow and orange are
the shortest live and the ones in the
blue counties are the long said people
there's a 25 year difference between the
longest with people and the short sleep
people in America is simply because of
the mineral supply in their soil where
their food is grown and whether or not
they fry food the ones in the blue don't
fry food and ones in the Reds and orange
and yellows due west southwest west the
Mississippi River Indian reservations
Old Confederate States in the
southeastern part of United States and
eastern seaboard same thing for males
statin drugs speed up aging process
women go through menopause in their 30s
low te D in males regardless of age
Allisyn disease we're now finding in 30
year olds and 20 years olds because it
has nothing to do with age nothing to do
with genetics it has to do with a
cholesterol deficiency if you're very
very
like vegetarians vegans who were really
driven to stay away from animal products
and cholesterol and saturated fat and
they take santen drugs many of them not
all but many of them and they're the
ones who have a high rate of alzheimers
disease and hormonal problems so I urge
everybody to get a hold of these books
black gene lies epigenetics immortality
and rares ventures and you'll learn why
the top 20 longevity cultures live so
long what is there what are the secrets
they have 23 common threads and of
course I'm going to show you what I
believe are the more important ones
after this after these pictures but I
want you to look at in March I look at
the cover of that book I'm going to look
at the top picture above that yellow
line just below the neck of that statue
there it's a fire I want you to pay
attention to that fire because this is
very very important and why the top
longevity country culture the top 20
longevity cultures are all third rule
cultures calorie restriction diets the
same top 20 longevity cultures only
taken 600 and 900 calories a day not
because they know the science they're
illiterate there are there are third
world cultures but they're so poor they
can only afford 600 and 900 calories a
day Americans taken 2,500 to 4,000
calories a day this fella here George
Francis died 112 in December of 2008 was
the longest live documented man in
America he lived considerably longer
than 19 presidents he lived through
whose average lion's mane was 75 the
doctors who cared for these presidents
documented their average lifespan came
out in 1999 in a big study published in
medical journals is 56 exactly half of
the years that George Francis got now he
lived in a house was a cabin that his
great granddaddy built during the slave
days potbelly stove dirt floor was a
crawdad fishermen and fishermen sold
those things to restaurants Cajun
restaurants and he lived behind 12
double the lifespan of medical doctors
who took care of presents so what was
the secret when he died his daughter was
asked by the reporters in his daughter's
reading the newspaper to him there the
daughter said when she was asked what
does your daddy do to Libby 112 she said
he broke all the rules of health eating
he cooked in lard and ate butter and
cream and eggs in fact she said his
entire diet was
dairy products eggs and large sandwiches
also in the right hand side you see the
Russian mismo lof' 168 years of age is a
very famous picture in the National
Geographic where he is working in his
tea plantation and also listening to a
transistor radio at 168 years of age man
from Syria died 133 years of age now
she's graphic cover may 2013 this baby
will live to be 120 look at the grammar
this baby will live to be 120 she's from
the decline Peninsula on the Pacific
coast of Costa Rica in Central America
the poorest of poor countries and
cultures on earth okay these are the
lots of people in the Western Hemisphere
what's going on here why do they have 40
times 100 as we do why do they have 100
per 250 their population we Americans
only have 110,000 this fellow's from
Bolivia the second longest live culture
in the Western Hemisphere he's putting
llama manure in his wood stove there's a
hi-tech kitchen he's 102 his fellow
hears from Florida when he turned 101 he
actually I got a hole-in-one on his
101st birthday we need to find out what
he does and make sure that Tiger Woods
gives the information these are long as
the people on earth the honza's from the
Hunza Valley in the Karakoram mountains
that separate northern Pakistan from
China they're the lungs of people on
earth they live at 13,000 feet elevation
and they're descendants of Alexander the
Great when he moved east from Greece
after he won all the battles there he
moved east towards a China and of course
having babies along the way these people
live at 13,000 foot elevation you can
see they're obviously third-world and
they live in what we would call the land
flowing with milk and honey the gilt our
glacier which is about a mile wide at
13,000 foot elevation okay the water
that comes out from underneath that gilt
our glacier looks like milk because the
glacier is grinding up limestone and so
the limestone powder comes out in the
water it looks like milk and bees love
minerals and so there's lots of bees
there the land flowing with milk and
honey this is biblical this is a
biblical location this is where people
did well they were successful in
business they were healthy they lived
long time had healthy children in okay
now it's not all open I was live well or
long there's only a very small group of
people up in one
mountain on the side of one mountain
they live to be an average of 85
everybody else does to be 52 to 60 so
it's not all of okay now with the lives
well it's just one little subculture now
the reason is of course we'll get into
in a second we spend a lot of time with
this fella here mr. Taguchi is 102 years
old and he lives in this little
subculture up on the side of this
mountain and so we know exactly what
they do to live so long and here's the
oldest gal up there is she's a pop star
she goes around with a singing group and
she's the lead singer in a singing group
singing pop songs and you can just tell
by looking at her her energy is just
tremendous she's from the island of Ko
Hama in Okinawa in the last 300 years
this is the longest-lived of humanity
that's documented dr. Ewen ching-yuen li
and chinese always put their last name
first so Chang Hyun Lee died 256 years
of age he's born in 1677 died May 6 1933
and he lives in a place that is rich
with rare earths in laboratory animals
rare earths double the life span
laboratory animals compared to the
control group okay we use them in
electronics we know they were very
valuable for electronics but also
they're required yet erbium metrium
neodymium prosody meum europium and
samarium and of course they're all in
the nineties essential nutrients in all
60 essential minerals we need water for
life we need oxygen for life you need
the 90 essential nutrients for life your
DNA RNA your genes your telomeres a
little end caps on your chromosomes will
fail without these nutrients you have to
have them every second every minute
every hour every day every week of every
month of every year otherwise you're
gonna have problems it's just that
simple you cannot live without them you
need 60 minerals 16 vitamins 12 amino
acids three fatty acids you have to have
them your genes your DNA RNA and
telomeres must have these things
otherwise you have the greatest genes in
the world but they're not going to
perform this is when I first understood
epigenetics
epigenetics has replaced genetics when
it comes to the understanding of disease
longevity this is a study we did at the
st. Louis Zoo when I was doing all those
autopsies back in the 1960s and 70s and
ended up in that book which is in the
Smithsonian Institute the disease of
exotic animals and Monsanto gave the st.
Louis Zoo because we're in the newspaper
all the time because of these studies
going on
st. Louis Zoo a a timed Hydra hydro
panic unit and these big racks with all
these trays and had seeds from barley
grass and on a timer with water and
fertilizers and we would be able to
harvest this like weekly it's just
wonderful for the zoo animals eating dry
food and hay all the time no green grass
it's really a wonderful thing and
Perkins who was from the st. Louis Zoo
obviously in the TV show okay
mutual maja was Wild Kingdom I said okay
Wallach to find out of what real value
is this Hydra is it's just fun for these
animals or we just you know wasting
their time errs are useful for them and
so I was able to steal eggs from the
same mother father common mallard ducks
farm ducks
I stole 100 eggs over a period of three
months put them in refrigerator just
like an put human frozen embryos and in
the freezer just put them in
refrigerator when I get had 100 I divide
them into four groups of 25 the first
group of 25 I just gave let us see for
six weeks the second group of 25 I gave
nothing but the hydroponically grown
barley grass and you can see it's about
10-15 percent maybe even 20 percent
bigger than the ones that just got the
lettuce the one in the middle with the
little little scale or the little ruler
on it received the ralston purina
laboratory duck pellets see is double
the size of the other two but the one
that really got optimal amounts of every
nutrient need to maximize his genetic
potential for size and strength and
everything it can do was we call the
Huey group it got both the pellets the
alfalfa pellets from Ralston Purina and
the barley grass look at the difference
they're the same exact genes same mother
father incubated at the same time and so
there's no doubt that this is an
epigenetic story here in that study the
center for blockage of natural systems
we eliminated 900 different diseases and
animals which still plague people
because we realize there were
nutritional deficiency we increase the
nutritional supplementation of zoo
animals and eliminate all the diseases
and of course this is what saved the
Panda the pandas were down to just maybe
a dozen pan is left in zoos and they're
about raid all died out then suddenly we
heard about Ling Ling right suddenly had
all these other baby pants what's
happening I finally got to do an autopsy
I'm one of them
and it was just starving to death
because we're feeding it nothing but
bamboo and so I said let's give him some
dog food
well you can't this an exotic animal you
can't give him dog food so we gave him
dry dog food and now we have more pan as
we know what to do is they I got to give
him birth control okay
we've tripled the lifespan of animals
with this information and basically if
you look back sixty years ago an old dog
was eight years old ten a total dog is
25 and the same system time span
we humans have added two or three months
to our lifespan we didn't ripple it like
we did for animals because we're using
drugs and we used nutrition for animals
we eliminate every birth defects you can
name in ten times that many can't in
animals by supplementing preconception
and I urge everybody I urge everybody
when you're getting a couple this dating
strong a couple is getting engaged or a
couple is getting married do not give
him a gift card yeah I give them
monogrammed towels did I give him a
linen set to start their household give
him the 90 essential nutrients and then
you won't be a grandmother babysitting a
special-needs child
how did rich people get their minerals
back thousands of years ago they'd give
him grave robbers big bags of silver and
gold to get mummies and bring them
mummies they grind up the mummies into
mummy dust and they would use mummy dust
as a condiment like salt and pepper on
their food they're getting the minerals
from the Mummy's bones and skin and
vitamins and from their livers and so
forth they did get some supplements that
way and they live longer and healthier
now obviously people who are slaves and
and subsistence farmers and people who
were just carpenters couldn't afford big
bags of gold and silver to get mummies
where'd they get their minerals well
Santi of American did a wonderful story
on why people began to live longer we're
healthier were smarter did things
invented language and so forth invented
writing and they said it was all becuase
of cooking food it all happened when
food began to be cooked and that's
exactly right but it wasn't because of
the cooked food but it began when food
was cooked but not because of the cooked
food now what was the universal fuel
three four five thousand years ago would
no matter where in the world they burns
fuel for heat for cooking for defense
whatever it was the fuel was always wood
and what did they do with the wood ashes
every morning you'd throw them in the
recycling bin to save the earth where
did the wood ashes go it went into the
garden wood ashes aren't
95% to 98% of the wouldn't really
minerals if the trees sucked up out of
the ground when you burnt the wood that
powder that's left is minerals sometimes
a little gray or black because there's
some carbon left over but 95 to 98% of
what we would call wood ash there's
really minerals that the tree had sucked
up or the ground we threw it in the
garden and everybody knew it increased
fertility had a better yield your
gardens is better when you put wood
ashes in there but what they didn't know
and yet today they don't know and I'm
depending on all of you to share this
information but they didn't know and
they don't know today is those plants
sucked up those minerals when you ate
the pumpkins in the squash and the okra
and the tomatoes and bell peppers and
you ate the potatoes and onions and the
peas and beans and lentils and and corn
that were grown there they sucked up all
those minerals and that's how you got
your meal you didn't know you were
getting your nutritional minerals that
way but you did this remains the same
for thousands and thousands and
thousands of years until 3 o'clock in
the afternoon Monday September 4th 1882
at 3 o'clock in the afternoon Monday
September 4th 1882 on Pearl Street in
New York City and the bluff overlooking
the construction of the Brooklyn Bridge
it all ended in a single heartbeat we
know this because the story was in every
newspaper in the world this fella here
Thomas Edison pulled the switch in the
first commercial electric generating
plant when ten years every
industrialized nation including United
States every town in every city in every
industrialized nation converted from
wood as Universal fuel to electricity
here comes the ultimate question how
many wood ashes are left over in your
home every morning when you use
electricity to fuel your home zero zero
now nobody knew what was happening they
still don't and again the most fertile
and the most valuable farmland in the
world thousands of years ago and yet
today her flood plains because every
spring that would flood and as the water
would recede it would leave silt and mud
behind minerals if you will from
mountains hundreds or maybe thousands of
miles upstream and people like this of
course they'd plow this in and renew the
mineral content of this all cuz when you
have minerals in the food just because
the plants are pulling minerals out of
the soil they don't know it they don't
need it they only need three but they'll
take up anything that's soluble in the
soil people liked it
guess what today we have 900,000 dams
for hydroelectric power 900,000 dams
for hydroelectric power and of course
there was an unintended consequence
flood
control now people thought that was good
at first did you realize that we
destroyed the earth with flood control
because there's no renewal of the
minerals in the soil the farm lambs are
the plains or where was flooding the
valleys and we've shut off the food
supply to herself we've shut off her
minerals for herself as you'll see in a
moment we have exact numbers by the US
Department of Agriculture so things are
happening it's all negative because
we've dammed up the rivers that cut off
the food supply to our farms we've cut
off the food supply to the ocean it's
over 100 feet deep of minerals that have
piled up since they've built the Hoover
Dam these crucial minerals do not a
Kearney uniform Blanc around the coast
of yours nutritional minerals occur in
veins like chocolate and chocolate ice
cream some places have little some
places have none some places have three
minerals some places that have 15 some
places of 25 some places have 40 but you
can see from this picture which is a
satellite picture from a hundred miles
up that the different colors and the
swirls and whirls represent different
minerals and different combinations and
minerals so in the animal industry so
every dairy cow is eating hay or beans
soybeans grown in this area we would put
a supplement of vitamins and minerals in
there alfalfa pellets may be grown there
Arthur soybeans grown there so put the
vitamins minerals in their food so we're
leveling the playing field so every
dairy cow no matter what part of that
picture she got her food from she's
gonna give us a maximum yield say a gal
and a half a milk instead of 10% of the
cow is giving a pint and 20% giving a
quart instead of all 100% giving her a
gallon and a half it's predictable it is
also very nutritional because a lot of
these minerals appear in the milk if
they're there they're not there I mean
say the cow can't make them now this is
what makes youngevity unique this is a
compost pile this compost pile goes back
into prehistoric days it's made out of
100 cent green leafy plants we know this
because of the chloroplast
the little chloro chlorophyll structures
inside plants for eating leafy things
and they contain 78 minerals all 60
essential minerals an optical mouse
these people are standing in a row
that's 3,000 foot elevation above sea
level that white cap on this deposit is
15 to 25 foot thick and it represents a
cap of marine limestone so obviously
wonder
see for thousands and thousands and
thousands years to make this limestone
and there's a hundred cubic miles of
this stuff here in this deposit 100
cubic miles we know this from drillings
and soundings because oh gosh a 50 75
years ago people are looking for oil
we're looking for coal they're looking
for natural gas in these places and they
said what is this stuff this isn't what
we're looking for they just deserted it
of course this is something that is
incorporated into our 90 essential
nutrients getting the 60 essential
minerals from this deposit we knew in
1936 our soil was depleted in minerals
this is a US Senate document 264 and it
was a two-year hearings done by the US
Senate to determine why our Sol's were
did why did we have the Dust Bowl why
did we have the Great Depression they
blamed it on depletion of minerals in
the soil in 1936 but nobody proposed the
reason why our saw was depleted if you
ask even yet today environmentalists
professors of agriculture and big
agricultural universities yes and why is
our soil so depleted of minerals we'll
always say because of for permanent
farming practices because of poor
farming practices that's not true
nothing has changed as far as farming
practices we plow we plant we harvest we
plow we plant we harvest and so what is
it well no more wood ashes in the
gardens no more silt from floods and
we've cut off the food supply to our
land cut off the food supply to our
oceans
that's why we're in trouble this is one
that really disturbs me our baby food
according to the Food Chemistry Journal
which comes out every month I read it
faithfully every month and this one came
out April 16 2012 they looked at the top
eight baby formulas from the standpoint
of pollution and from nutritional value
and they said these baby formulas we're
talking we're talking about Enfamil
Similac Gerber's ones you're very
familiar with very well-respected these
babies foods contain less than 20% of
the required nutrients needed for proper
development of our babies we're talking
about 20% of the minerals and vitamins
our babies need is all you're going to
get and giving them these baby food if
you don't supplement you're gonna wind
up burying them like Joe Biden buried
his son Beau Steve Jobs mother buried
him and Iwata's mother buried him okay
you're gonna wind up bearing your
children if you don't supplement them
because it's not in the food anymore
even from the very beginning
okay these baby farm moves you must
supplement we do it in animals we got
great results we have to do it in people
we're gonna have to do this the
government has failed us and guess what
the medical system has failed us
terribly and somebody needs to go to
jail this is a hundred year study from
1914 to 2014 and of course they referred
back to US Senate document 264 published
in 1936 our farm cells are depleted of
vital metals and as a result our foods
are literally starved of nutrition
medicine cannot compensate for the
sufficiency u.s. Senate document 264
1936 and the minerals in our soil over
the past hundred years 1914 to 2014 have
been depleted by 85 percent you'll see
the chart and the graph on the right you
see the the extreme dip in the mineral
values of our soil okay then in the
bottom line and again this comes from
last year 2014 USDA the United States
Department of Culture reports that 95
percent of all Americans are mentally
deficient what more do you need what
more do you need to understand that you
must supplement no matter how well you
eat you're a billionaire doesn't matter
you're an athlete it doesn't matter if
you're a farmer doesn't matter if you
don't supplement you're in trouble
worse yet if you don't supplement and
supplement your children your children
are in trouble remember the experts are
saying that our children our children
will be the first generation of
Americans that do not live as long as
their parents to me that's very very
scary but we have the power we have the
knowledge to fix this but we're gonna
have to be very proactive here because
the government's not going to do it and
guess what the doctors aren't gonna do
it I want you to look at these maps the
United States again I don't you look at
the demographics here look at the worst
of the worst and then here the dark blue
okay this is disability rates look at
the dark blue ones which is the worst of
the worst 31% the dark blue states of
disability look at this one and this one
you look at this one this is the heart
age compared to the actual chronological
age and ones in the dark burgundy are
the worst of the worst same demographic
look at this one
heart disease same demographic
southeastern states the Old Confederate
states the states in the Great Lakes
area and west of the Mississippi River
the Indian
in the northwest and the Southwest okay
and now we're gonna look at cancer same
thing Old Confederate States the states
around the Great Lakes in the northwest
and the Southwest where the Indian
reservations are eastern seaboard worst
of the worst life expectancy as you
would expect with all these terrible
diseases being the worst in those places
same demographics the blue areas there's
his bike County actually live 25 years
longer than the ones and the orange and
the yellow and the red both in the Old
Confederate States the Great Lakes areas
out west northwest and the Indian
reservations in the southwest there's
both for males and females the way we've
been doing this for 38 years and we've
been doing this commercially for 38
years is to supplement with all 90
essential nutrients and of course we
have a thousand products it's very
difficult for a stranger to come along
as we look at all to say oh my gosh they
throw their hands up what do I do
is there a key to this and of course the
FDA won't let us save for this disease
use this product they don't like that so
we had to come at this a different way
what we had to do was come up with
systems where one program dealt with
many many diseases okay and you can't
just use the Cure word so we had to do
it in a different way
so let's look at what we call the basic
Healthy Start pack there's three
products in there has 245 nutrients many
will be in the near future declared
essential so we were already putting
them in there but it also has the 90
essential nutrients 16 minerals 16
vitamins 12 amino acids 3 fatty acids in
optimal amounts for perfect biochemical
nutrition for a hundred pounds of human
flesh for a month give it to a 50 pound
kid it's a 2 month supply
give it to a 30 pound kids to three
month supply here's a 200 pound person
you need two of these per month the 300
pound person eight three four months and
so on and this is the basic stuff now
I've essentially been doing it not this
farm but I've been doing it personally
for 68 years I haven't been sick in 68
years never even had a cold I've never
had any surgery I've never been on a
prescription medication my resting pulse
without prescription without a drug
without any medication is 90 over 60
my resting pulse without any medication
is 36 now does spike when I get angry
you're upset it'll spike to 39 it's been
that way since I was 18
Alma's wrestling for the University of
Missouri in playing football in high
school for four years lettering and
football in wrestling so this is our
basic program if you don't have a lot of
money this will cost you about three
dollars a day for the average person per
hundred pounds of body weight and this
is what I've been doing the healthy
essentially the healthy start pack but
let's say you have something like you're
overweight by 50 75 100 pounds or more
200 pounds 300 pounds you want the
healthy weight loss pack we have
everything in there you need to give
your body what it needs so your cravings
go away so your munchies go away and we
give your body what it likes so that it
will give you everything it needs it'll
make what it can to keep you in the
healthy weight range and you'll lose
anywhere from a half a pound of two
pounds a day and you'll never gain the
weight back as long as you stay on this
program and then of course if you have
diabetes type 2 type 1 if you have
anxiety attacks panic attacks narcolepsy
anything that has to do with pleasure
problems
hypoglycemia reactive hypoglycemia you
want the healthy blood sugar pack one of
those 400 pounds of body weight you know
when you have diabetes you just take
your fasting blood sugar before you
medicate yourself and as your blood
sugar drops you just do what your doctor
says reduce your medication if your
blood Sugar's up you do what your doctor
says you take more medication and you'll
know when it's time to get off your
medication and to aging healthy body
Peck people who have wrinkles and age
spots and just retired all the time
because they're in their 70s and 80s you
give them a healthy anti-aging Peck and
the body's defenses can get rid of the
age spots when you give it the raw
materials to do that and of course we
have the healthy brain and heart Pet the
healthy brain and heart pack actually
gives you everything you need to deal
with over I don't know about one hundred
and forty seven different diseases and
we're talking about Parkins ease Lou
Gehrig's disease which is als also MS
multiple sclerosis Huntington's disease
Alzheimer's disease and all the other
dementia also congestive heart failure
cardiomyopathy heart disease coronary
heart disease in the history of
thrombotic stroke the healthy brain and
heart pack one per 100 pounds of body
weight okay and then you have the
healthy body digestive pack you have
reflux belching burping bloating gas
these sorts of things you want the
healthy digestive pack and there is no
such thing as acid reflux it really
should be renamed
lack of acid reflux okay because you
really don't have enough stomach acid so
yeast will grow and their bacterial go
in there and they ferment carbohydrates
and sugar making gas and causing all
these problems so my suggestion is if
you have reflux don't take any of these
PPI is a proton pump inhibitors so that
you are gonna make less stomach acid
because in two three four five years
time you're gonna have fifteen disease
you didn't have before you all be
nutritional deficiency diseases so you
want the healthy digestive pack one four
hundred pounds of body weight healthy
body athletic pack if you're working
hard and you're trading you're sweating
you want this one if you're playing
sports on the weekend or you're just
kind of two three nights a week you're
going to the gym and running on the
treadmill and working on the machines
you want to use a healthy body aesthetic
pack and also if you have people in your
family who are in school
and they're playing sports whether it's
in grade school junior high high school
or university or if they're trying out
for the Olympic team or you know
professional football players or even if
you have somebody in the military
because the government does not give our
military vitamins minerals they give
them dry food they give them canned food
but they do not get any vitamins
minerals I have surveyed thousands of
military personnel many of whom had PTSD
they do not get any vitamins minerals
from the government so if you have
somebody you love who is in the military
I'd urge you to give them the healthy
body athletic pack it has all the
minerals that are missing the result in
the diseases that are diagnosed as PTSD
depression make depression bipolar
disease and so on and then healthy body
bone and joint pack if you have
arthritis osteoporosis bone de Barros
fridays osteopenia osteoporosis
periodontal disease which is
osteoporosis of the face you take the
healthy bone and joint pack and guess
what happens your body has the ability
to rebuild itself your body wants to
heal itself but you have to give it raw
materials for that to happen you cannot
build a house without brick and mortar
you cannot build a house without roofing
shingles you cannot build a house
without wood for framing and
infrastructure you need nails and screws
and bolts and nuts okay same way with
their body you may have the best genes
in the world but without the nineties
essential nutrients as they say in
France or ain't nothing going to happen
okay
and so I just hope you remember the fact
that we have less than 20% of the
nutrients necessary our baby foods our
kids generation will be the first
generation America that do not live as
long as their parents
it's not a genetic thing it's not
destined but if you don't supplement
them that that prediction will come true
so I urge you to give everybody you know
for birthdays holidays anytime a
presents due for graduations in schools
and so forth getting married getting
engaged going out together on a regular
basis give them the 90 essential
nutrients our babies will be born normal
people will live a long time your kids
will outlive you which is the way it's
supposed to be and I want to thank you
for being such a great audience
contact your young giving associate and
find out how you get involved become
part of the youngevity nation and we're
gonna save America even more important
than that with this information we can
save the world and god bless you